I was in the same room as all these
legends and with all these new people
who are pure want to be legends obsessed
you know it's being done with such love
and such enthusiasm from everybody and I
think that you'll be able to feel that
coming off the screen it means so much
to so many people you just know what's
gonna be like in the cinema star was
just an important part of everyone's
history it's a beautiful thing to
actually be involved in it
hey youtubers is charlie so this is
going to be my breakdown of the Star
Wars Episode 7 footage from comic-con
instead of bringing like like a
traditional trailer they brought a bunch
of BTS footage and did a whole bunch of
stuff they actually had a pretty badass
presentation even even though everyone
was really excited about Deadpool stuff
I think that Star Wars had one of the
better actual presentations so here we
go we start on the planet of jakku
that's Ray's home obviously it looks a
lot like Tatooine but it's a completely
different planet the events of this film
will pick up after what is being called
the battle of jakku so imagine like the
Battle of Endor just leaving a lot of
debris this isn't the same thing but
it's similar to that that that's why we
see the Star Destroyer in the trailer
that's been crashed on the planet moving
to interior of the Millennium Falcon
obviously very familiar who else got
really excited when it looked like they
hadn't cleaned this in 30 years
seriously if you had a black light it
looked like a Jackson Pollock painting
this is an interior the Imperial base
they said they say that the main base
for the first order is being called the
Starkiller base just an homage of luke
skywalker's original name in the script
he was he was originally called Luke
Starkiller but then George Lucas changed
it they did a lot of that in the film
it's the same thing with Star Wars
rebels were they basing a lot of the
visual look on Ralph mccourys concept
art so when they say they're going back
to the source material they're going
back to George Lucas's source material
that he used to build his movies on
shadow r2d2 looking a little bit older
but none the worse for wear the
background almost looks like the Jawa
sandcrawler from a new hope this is one
of the first shots we saw of the first
order stormtroopers way back when they
release the very first trailer then we
get a shot at two new aliens presumably
somewhere on jakku it seems like most of
the shots that aren't happening on the
Imperial base are happening on jakku we
don't know anything about what race
either of them are they could be
completely new aliens they created for
the film I think that that was their
intention just to make things look like
stuff from the class of trilogy but be
completely new a lot of people are
calling her like the new slave leia but
i'm not going to think of her that way
just because it doesn't look quite that
salacious which is interesting because
the name of Java's pit was salacious
crumb he was a shot of a crashed first
order type fighter the only thing that
looks really different about this is the
fact that they gave it the black paint
job otherwise it looks pretty close to
the classic Thai fighter
there are rumors that this could be
Finn's TIE fighter another interior shot
of the Falcon they essentially whenever
they were shooting the film they built
like a full millennium falcon to scale
so they could shoot inside of it I'm
waiting for Lucasfilm to release a 3d
video of it or even like a 360 video
they did that it with a warcraft movie
legendary released a 360 degree video
where you could just pan around a look
at stormwind more new practical aliens
there's a there's a ton of CG in the
film they were really honest about that
but they tried to build as much stuff as
possible if you look in the background
though there is a picture of Admiral
Ackbar so he could totally appear in
this movie or we could at least see Mon
Calamari this is a shot of Oscar Isaacs
character Poe Dameron on the Imperial
base the Starkiller base this is lupita
in mocap the name of her character is
Maz Kanata we don't know what she looks
like but I'm pretty excited Andy Serkis
is also playing a full mocap character
rumored to be like the new emperor level
big bad here's a shot of three pio
getting put together he has a red arm in
this movie for some reason we don't have
any idea why but presumably he's broken
down a couple more times in the time
since episode 6 so that they needed to
repair them with spare parts this is
actually just a shot of the film camera
they're shooting on just to show you
that they are shooting on actual film
it's the same type of film stock that
they shot the original trilogy on here's
more shots of them shooting in Tunisia
in the desert they shot a lot of this in
the desert Tunisia is just where they've
shot all of the desert scenes in all of
the Star Wars movies so even though this
movie won't feature Tatooine it will
look a lot like Tatooine this is a shot
of Poe Dameron running around one of the
new blue x-wings here's a shot of adam
drivers character kylo Ren descending
from his ship it definitely gives you a
vibe of Darth Vader walking down the
troop transport during Return of the
Jedi this is one of the new flame
troopers there's just a couple
variations on the different types of
first order stormtroopers chrome trooper
right now is my favorite which is
Wendell and Christie's character here's
a shot of Simon Pegg confirming that
he's in the film he has like a like a
full-blown suit so it seems like he's
playing a creature he might be providing
some sort of performance and his voice
but like his face simon Pegg's face
won't be in the movie he won't look like
himself here's official Chewie on set in
costume
I think it's nice that they asked him
back that they asked Peter Mayhew back
because they could have put anybody in
that suit and just done his voice it
should be noted that Daisy Ridley is
sitting and Han Solo seeds ammonium
Falcons sitting in the captain's chair
but this could be them just hanging out
on set here's the shadow with the
resistance x-wing TIE fighter helmets
are going to look like the resistance is
what the rebellion is called in these
films so the rebels exist but they're
called the resistance just like the
first order is what the Empire becomes
here's actually what looks like one half
of a GOG droid which i think is kind of
funny it's nice that they brought that
back here's a shot of a red and black
stormtrooper that we haven't seen before
it is just like one of the other new
variations that we don't know about yet
more interior and exterior shots of the
Falcon obviously this is going to be one
of the shots of the gun turrets here's a
shot of 3p oh and what looks like the
rebel base from a new hope I'm expecting
this to be somewhere else though I don't
think that they'll go back to Yavin
here's Donal Gleeson out of costume we
found out that he's playing a villain
named general Hux in the first order the
people on the panel made a joke about
British people always playing villains
just you know just because Gwendoline
Christie another Brit in the film also
playing an evil character we really
don't know what's going on with Donal
Gleason's character other than that he's
a general so he's probably the one with
adam drivers character giving orders
here's another shot of JJ Abrams and
Lawrence Kasdan sitting on that first
order based the Starkiller base this
even looks like an up close shot of
Admiral Ackbar here's a shot at Carrie
Fisher in costume she actually looks
pretty awesome here's Oscar Isaac
without his helmet on he said that his
character believes himself to be the
best damn pilot in the galaxy so we'll
see how that goes whenever he meets Han
Solo they didn't say officially when
we're gonna get the next trailer
probably sometime in November I mean
they were kind of vague about that but
when we get within about six weeks of
the movie will probably get another big
one they didn't say a whole lot about
the anthology films that are going to be
taking place between episode seven eight
and nine but they'll probably start
releasing more information as we get
closer to episode seven what's going to
happen is is that every year they want
to release a new Star Wars movie so like
every two years they'll have like one of
the new big films like episode seven
eight nine and then in between those
they'll have the anthology films we
already know we're getting a han solo
film we're getting another film called
red 5 which is like a story that takes
place in
the past it's the story of the rebels
stealing the plans for the death star so
even though a lot of these spin-off
films will close gaps between movies
they'll also jump back in time so we
will get to see stuff from the classic
trilogy stuff from that era but let me
know what you guys think about the
footage I mean did this get you excited
for the film I know everyone was a
little disappointed they didn't show new
trailer but think about it this way they
took everyone to a live concert with
John Williams so it's like they
literally bent over backwards to do
something awesome for the audience at
comic-con it's one of those Deadpool
situations where the cast and the
producers of the film acknowledged that
this would not be happening if not for
the fans like the fans are the reason
that these movies are getting made so
what's going to happen later tonight is
I have a couple more trailers that I
need to work through but I'm seeing
ant-man tonight so I'm going to post a
non-spoilery review of that next that
probably won't post till friday morning
but be sure to subscribe to get i'll do
like an easter egg video with spoilers
after that like after everyone has a
chance to see it so while you guys wait
for all that stuff to post you can click
here for all my comic con trailer
breakdowns I just posted a warcraft one
just a heads up they changed some stuff
about the lore in the movie so a lot of
people were a little confused about the
breakdown that I did and you can click
here for my break down to the Deadpool
footage thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight me me me me
you